[Música]
los candidatos conservadores que aspiran
convertirse en el próximo primer
ministro del reino unido continúan su
campaña haciendo todos los últimos
esfuerzos para así convencer a los
diputados que elegirán a los últimos dos
más votados el ex secretario de economía
registre una que lidera las votaciones
seguido de fenimore diana secretaria del
comercio y strauss la secretaria asuntos
exteriores los tories también en las
votaciones para suceder al primer
ministro boris johnson quien luego de
todas las flexiones de lento de su
partido renunció por los escándalos de
los cuales será el protagonista entre
ellos el más conocido el pari gate
salvamos a indiana a share y es
licenciada en ciencia política por la
uba y también maestra anda en sociología
política internacional por la
universidad nacional de tres de febrero
gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente indiana en directo américa de
france 24 cómo están entonces las cosas
dentro del partido conservador británico
buenos días primero que nada muchas
gracias por contar conmigo la verdad que
la situación hoy por hoy busca
busca acomodarse en lo que son los
próximos días sobre todo porque este
próximo jueves el parlamento británico
entraría en vacas y los digamos las
sesiones terminarían este próximo jueves
para reunir a reanudarse recién el 5 de
septiembre un momento en el cual se
espera que ya haya un candidato o
candidata definida en los últimos días
como bien señalados lo que estoy
moviendo fueron los diferentes debates
televisivos entre los candidatos y las
candidatas para
una situación que se sucedía en las
diferentes votaciones en las cuales las
primeras tres salió como el primer
ganador podríamos decir risas una en
esta situación lo que vemos es que de lo
que eran los ocho candidatos iniciales
ahora solamente quedan cuatro reyes una
en ybor dance listas y que me vaya de no
porque el último diríamos que es el
único hombre que quedó en esta claro en
esta selección final
frente a esto entonces lo que tenemos es
que las de las mujeres las favoritas
dentro de lo que es el partido
conservador serían penny more than que
les digas una en votos y listas como
llevamos entonces al tener a estas dos
mujeres llamó snacks fue ministro
hacienda o el primer candidato en
presentarse a estas serie de elecciones
para la búsqueda desde el primer
ministro dentro del partido conservador
y le siguieron entonces por dante que
fue decíamos la segunda empresa en tarde
ella fue
secretaria de estado para la política
comercial de teresa mesa tenemos una
figura una mujer preparada claro y tiene
una trayectoria en política misma y por
otro lado entonces tenemos la figura de
lis atrás
de hecho en los últimos días en lo que
fueron los debates televisados que hubo
entre listas y sunat hubo una atención
ahí en frente a lo que había sido la
alta de
impuestos el manejo de algunos temas de
la pandemia que de hecho tenían que
encontrarse nuevamente en un próximo
encuentro
televisado y decidieron no participar
ninguno de los dos ahora también indiana
hay una cosa muy particular porque
digamos que en estas votaciones
primarias donde van a quedar dos
candidatos y luego se van a enfrentar
digamos a la votación de todos los
conservadores que son unos aproximados
200.000 vuelvo en los diputados pues
está entonces como favorito el más
votado risis unax pero también es se
maneja pues la posibilidad de que penn y
muerdan va a ser la más votada digamos a
nivel nacional en estos 200 mil
conservadores e institutos en todo reino
unido no en el partido entonces qué va a
pasar mejor y si es una que digamos como
un ganador inicial dentro de los
diputados entre un grupo selecto pero en
la mayoría del partido en las bases del
partido está más popular y tiene más
apoyo
cómo es esto
y aprendí lo que tenemos que ver es
esperar ponerle hasta el jueves para que
termine de limpiar los candidatos
paramos y quienes quedan si
efectivamente terminan quedando una como
frente a este escenario la situación
sería bastante compleja en el sentido de
por un lado tenemos una figura una mujer
que podría de alguna forma renovar
el puesto de primera ministra después lo
que había sido la trayectoria de theresa
may y
entendiendo también que las bases del
partido conservador de los tories están
mucho más en una línea mucho más afín a
lo que propone en morgan el rey es una
por su parte y también otra cuestión que
siguen va ganando en las votaciones es
uno de los actores que estuvo vinculado
al caso del partido entonces en el caso
de la votación final esto podría
generarle posteriores problemas al
momento de cosechar votos digamos a
quien sea que se enfrenta los retos
mayores que tendría el próximo primer
ministro de reino unido hablando de
política interna con la política externa
cómo sería entonces también la relación
con la unión europea el break sin la
situación con irlanda del norte a que se
enfrenta este nuevo primer ministro
también por supuesto la crisis
energética derivada de la guerra en
ucrania
cómo voy a enseñarlas entonces tenemos
una agenda partida en los problemas
internos y los problemas externos por un
lado a la cuestión interna y tenemos la
falta de lo que es mano de obra un
montón de sectores también como
consecuencia de esta de esta salida
libre existe salida tan tardía y con
tantas problemas en el medio por lo cual
pensando en la excanciller pensando la
figura que femenina que estuvo
negociando las cuestiones de esta de
esta salida de la unión europea
podríamos tener abordar como un
personaje interesante para abordar esta
situación lo mismo por lo que son otras
cuestiones vinculados a la obra decidir
cómo podríamos decir la cuestión de la
relación entre las dos irlandas irlanda
del norte de irlanda propiamente dicha y
por otro lado lo que tenemos es una gran
alza de impuestos como consecuencia de
la crisis obviamente de la pandemia el
coronavirus y lo que es obviamente hoy
por la guerra de ucrania lamentablemente
siguen pensamos en estas dos agendas por
separados la relación es tan intrínseca
que la persona sea primero primera
ministra que vaya para el cargo de boris
johnson va a tener que hacerle frente a
toda esta situación de manera global